doctors and attorneys say hundreds of
young people are living under inhumane
conditions at a Texas border control
station they say about they found about
250 babies children and teenagers
without adequate food water and
sanitation some of the children said
they've been detained there for weeks
Mireya Villarreal has reported
extensively from the border Maria joins
us now Maria where do they say this is
happening okay so this is actually
happening just outside of El Paso in a
town called vez it accounted a town
called Clint Texas it's about 20 miles
southeast of El Paso you know one
researcher told us that more than a
dozen children have the flu and some
were in quarantine cells without adult
supervision there were young girls in
this facility taking care of a sick
two-year-old boy who was in filthy
clothing without a diaper the children
said that they were fed uncooked frozen
food and had gone weeks without baby now
immigration officials could not be
reached for this story but you know for
months they have been saying that their
system and the facilities are
overwhelmed apprehensions in the El Paso
area specifically have spiked more than
600 percent since last year we've seen a
lot of this in our reporting over the
last year and a half now in May the
office of the Inspector General pointed
to dangerous overcrowding at the El Paso
facility specifically showing migrants
packed into holding cells as with
children and adults now according to
current rules children should only be
held in border patrol for 72 hours
before being transferred to Health and
Human Services which actually housed
migrant facilities but you know we've
spoken with immigration attorneys and
and advocates as well they are telling
us right now they are holding these
children for longer but they are moving
them to different detention facilities
so they stay within the parameters of
the Flores guidelines the more you hear
about this story the worse it gets and
my big concern a lot of people are
concerned that some of these kids will
never be reunited with their families
yeah that's part breaking to think about
it is a huge concern I think that that a
lot of times we're hearing the federal
government say that they can't find you
know parents still some of them have
been deported so that that factors into
this so on that point the the president
just gave his first interview to a
spanish-language Network Telemundo
and he was asked about child separations
and his administration's zero-tolerance
policy take a look at that when I became
president President Obama had a
separation policy I didn't have it he
had it
I brought the families together 2,800
children were reunited with their
parents in this last year after the zero
Cosby policy because I put it together
though that's because I put them
together under Obama you had tsundere
short order I'm at right no I put them
together I'm the one that that changed
the plan I inherited separation Obama
built the cages I didn't build them
Obama built the cages that's somewhat
Obama separated I'm the one that did a
presidential order bring in two parents
together all right you've got President
Trump they're saying he inherited the
separation policy and Obama built the
cages Maria what's the reality so here's
the reality yes during the Obama
administration and even previous
administrations there were separations
of family right the biggest difference
here is zero tolerance the president
last year with his administration
implemented zero tolerance policy which
basically means that if you cross the
border illegally you did not go through
the right Asylum channels you were going
to be held in federal court and charged
with a felony and you would absolutely
be separated from your children that was
the absolute that was a huge astiz
and we know that because we were in the
courts we saw the courts back up we knew
exactly what was happening so for him to
say that he wasn't separating children
and he actually was reuniting them
that's just that's just not the way
things went down there's always more to
this story thank you very much Maria yes